[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans le
débat de france 24 huitième jour de la
guerre en ukraine l'armée russe resserre
encore un peu plus son étau elle se
serait emparée de la ville de carson au
sud kharkiv est toujours sous les bombes
quant à la capitale kiev elle se prépare
à un assaut de grande ampleur face à
cette invasion russe à ses portes
l'europe a décidé ces derniers jours des
sanctions très dures contre moscou
certaines visent directement vladimir
poutine le président russe l'europe qui
a aussi annoncé une aide inédite de 450
millions d'euros pour fournir des armes
à l'ukraine alors assistons à un réveil
de l'europe notamment en matière de
défense sept unités européennes
affichées depuis une semaine peut-elle
durer les citoyens européens sont ils
prêts à payer les conséquences des
sanctions prises contre la russie on va
en débattre avec nos invités ce soir et
guillaume la seconde j'ai arias
consultant militaire pour france24
bonsoir patrick martin geniez enseignant
à sciences po spécialiste des questions
européennes et puis aurore laluque
députée européenne place publique et
économiste bonsoir à tous les trois
merci beaucoup d'être avec nous sur ce
plateau ce soir j'aimerais d'abord qu'on
écoute emmanuel macron le président
français qui s'est exprimé hier soir
devant les français sur cette guerre en
ukraine emmanuel macron qui souhaite que
l'europe prenne une nouvelle dimension
l'écoutent
notre europe dans cette épreuve démontre
comme elle l'a fait ces derniers mois
une unité remarquable
elle doit désormais accepté de payer le
prix de la paix de la liberté de la
démocratie
elle doit investir davantage pour moins
dépendre des autres continents et
pouvoir décider pour elles mêmes en
d'autres termes devenir une puissance
plus indépendantes plus souveraine nous
ne pouvons plus dépendre des autres et
notamment du gaz russe je défendrai une
stratégie d'indépendance énergétique
européenne puissance de paix enfin nous
ne pouvons pas dépendre des autres pour
nous défendre que ce soit sur terre sur
mer sous la mer dans les airs dans
l'espace ou le cyberespace
à cet égard notre défense européenne
doit franchir une nouvelle étape et à
bruxelles on retrouve tout de suite
notre correspondant jean jacques guéry
jean-jacques bonsoir emmanuel macron à à
l'issue de son discours annoncé un
sommet européen informel qui doit se
tenir les 10 et 11 mars et il sera
justement question de davantage de
souveraineté dans l'union européenne
ouais ça montre qu'ils aient un vrai
changement avant l'union européenne
c'est ce qu'on a pu comprendre hier soir
dé mode emmanuel macron est à bruxelles
ce mode souveraineté c'est devenu l'un
des plus longtemps plus depuis une
semaine et le début de cette invasion
russe en ukraine on l'entend dans
absolument toutes les réunions d'urgence
qui se succèdent ici mardi par exemple
s'est déroulée une réunion des ministres
de l'énergie un des points clés au menu
des discussions c'était pour reprendre
les mots de la ministre française de
l'énergie barbara pompili vers 7 heures
travaillées il faut qu'on travaille sur
la résilience du système énergétique
héros peu européen parce que les
chiffres sont là la guerre en ukraine
elle met en évidence de façon très crue
la dépendance de l'europe moscou fournit
à l'union européenne 40% de son gaz
naturel alors il ya des pistes pour
élargir le élargir le nombre de
fournisseurs par exemple ça pourrait
être une piste on pense à l'algérie à
l'azerbaïdjan aux états unis ou au qatar
mais pour l'instant ça reste des pistes
et dans son discours hier soir le
président français emmanuel macron on
l'a entendu il a parlé du nucléaire est
bien le nucléaire à cette occasion là il
pourrait revenir sur le devant de la
scène non seulement en france mais aussi
dans toute l'europe league hier c'était
au tour des ministres de l'agriculture
de se réunir là aussi on m'a parlé de
souveraineté mais de souveraineté
agricoles parce que si l'europe elle
exporte son blé et ben c'est pas le cas
pour toutes les productions céréalières
si on s'intéresse au maïs par exemple
ces dernières années le faisait venir la
moitié de ses importations d'ukraine et
bien évidemment aujourd'hui ce maïs il
ne viendra plus l'ukraine qui aurait
aussi un gros producteur de protéines
végétales des protéines qui servent à
l'alimentation animale du colza ou
tournesol par exemple et bien les terres
actuellement en jachère sur le
territoire de l'union elle pourrait
aujourd'hui être utilisé pour cucq et
pour cultiver pardon ces protéines qui
vont punir d'ukraine c'est une des
pistes encore avec tous les problèmes
évidemment que cela pose pour la
régénération des sols alors au delà de
l'agriculture de l'énergie effectivement
avec cette guerre à nos portes on parle
aussi beaucoup d'une défense européenne
et c'est une question qui va se poser de
plus en plus pour les dirigeants mais
sans doute franchi une nouvelle étape
vous en avez parlé tout à l'heure avec
la décision des états membres de se
consacrer en commun un demi milliard
d'euros à des achats d'armement pour
l'ukraine est aujourd'hui voir
l'allemagne et livrer des armes annoncé
à vouloir moderniser son armée et monte
et faire comme ça un changement total
dans sa politique traditionnelle de
défense on a peine quelques jours c'est
vraiment la preuve de ce changement de
paradigme auquel on assiste aujourd'hui
dans toute l'europe là aussi comme sur
tous les autres dossiers que je viens
d'évoquer il ya énormément énormément de
travail mais clairement la carrière en
ukraine aujourd'hui apparaît comme un
catalyseur en quelques jours tout a
changé en deux temps l'union merci
beaucoup jean jacques guéry en direct de
bruxelles j'aimerais justement qu'on
s'intéresse d'abord à cette europe de la
défense guillaume l'esconge arias
l'europe qui a avancé davantage en
quelques jours quand plusieurs années
est-ce qu'on assiste à un réveil de
l'europe sur cette question de la
défense depuis quelques jours alors le
problème en fait avait déjà été soulevée
il ya quelques temps de ça puisque il ya
il ya quelques semaines déjà josep
borrell le patron fait de la diplomatie
européenne disait qu' on ne pouvait pas
se contenter d'être un herbivore dans un
monde de carnivores géopolitique et
cette image là le montre bien
finalement on ne peut pas face à un
tyrannosaure ça me permettait de la
l'image on peut pas continuer dans cette
dans cette direction le fait est que
l'europe avait déjà après la crise du 2
de l'aco vide et là le plan de relance
imaginez déjà mettre plus d'argent dans
les investissements de défense même si
ça avait été très largement minorées par
rapport aux attentes notamment de la
france à dire dans le fond européen de
défense on a démis à peu près on l'avait
imaginé 13 milliards on en était à peu
près à 5,6 ce qui était déjà pas mal là
on se rend compte que finalement ce ne
sera pas suffisant on ne se sera un
compte que ça pas suffisant et en fait
votre correspondant le disait bien le
fait que l'allemagne soit finalement le
pays qui jette le plus rapidement
presque aux orties trente ans de
politique finalement elle a passé son
budget militaire à 2% du produit
intérieur brut on va écouter justement
ceux qui envisagent on va écouter
justement le chancelier allemand olaf
scholz
le budget fédéral 2022 d'autres à ce
fonds spécial d'un montant unique de 100
milliards d'euros nous utiliserons ces
fonds pour les investissements et les
projets d'armement nécessaires
et nous allons à partir de maintenant
d'année en année investir plus de 2 % de
notre pib dans notre défense
c'est un tabou qui a été brisé en
allemagne en seulement quelques jours
c'est vrai que là il faut s'imaginer
effectivement ce changement de braquet
parce qu'on passe d'un budget de la
défense a à peu près 1,4 en 5 % du pib à
une montée en puissance jusqu'à plus de
2% ça veut donc dire que grosso modo par
année l'allemagne va passer d'un budget
d'à peu près 45 à 50 milliards jusqu'à
un budget d'à peu près 80 90 100
milliards d'euros mais ce n'est pas le
tout de d'investir ou de monter à 2 % du
pib c'est sur quoi on va l'investir pour
une raison toute simple et c'est une
simple question de remise à niveau il y
avait eu ce tweet du chef d'état major
de l'armée de terre allemand n'utilisait
que la bundeswehr ou la buddha air c'est
à dire l'armée de terre n'était pas en
mesure de fournir des options aux
politiques ça montre bien que finalement
tout est à reconstruire et donc ce n'est
pas simplement en une nuit qu'on va
pouvoir acheter des bateaux moderniser
des chats forme et déforme aînés et puis
bien tout simplement même déjà peut être
même en recruter certains c'est donc
cette transformation ça va prendre du
temps et je pense que la dimension
européenne elle est intéressante à
prendre en compte parce que il va y
avoir cet investissement dans le temps
long c'est aussi la pologne qui annonce
porter à 3% de son pib l'effort de
défense donc c'est un mouvement qui est
suivie mais c'est un mouvement fait qui
a commencé un peu plus tôt en 2014 au
sommet de newport les alliés de l'otan
avaient déjà envisagé que pour 2024 il
porterait tous leurs efforts à 2% du pib
pour l'instant 2021 2022 on est à dix
alliés sur 30 et il va falloir en fait
allé un peu plus longue la vie que vous
vouliez réagir sur ce point là en fait
il ya deux tabous qui sont levés côté
allemand c'est à dire déjà dépensé
d'argent public tout simplement il ya
des questions budgétaires au niveau
allemand qui sont quand même assez
spécifique et la question effectivement
de l'armement donc là ça se fait
malheureusement dans la douleur c'est ça
que moi je regrette c'est à dire qu'il
n'ya pas eu d'anticipation
ça fait des années qu'on ait un certain
nombre de plaider pour une europe de la
défense non pas pour attaquer c'est un
sujet qui est cher aussi à emmanuel
macron le préserve sujet c'est une
espèce ça dure depuis les années 50
finalement et les américains nous
avaient prévenus d'ailleurs à plusieurs
reprises -la avec l'élection de joe
biden les avertissements étaient
beaucoup plus clair en me disant si un
problème avec la russie et la chine vous
êtes seul vous êtes riche vous êtes
capable en fait d'avoir un moment vous
aussi votre propre défense c'est un peu
dommage que ça se passe dans ces
conditions-là mais oui l'europe n'a
jamais avancer avancer aussi vite et
puis on est en train de de payer une
construction défaillante si vous voulez
de l'europe sont en fait l'europe si on
la fait pas et il nous faut à son
fédéral en fait on a vu pendant la crise
du coc vide on a besoin d'une europe de
la santé on a besoin d'une europe
sociale n'a besoin d'une injure comment
l'europe on a besoin d'un budget
européen aujourd'hui l'europe est elle
paraît plus forte dans les crises elle
s'est renforcée patrick martin geniez
avec la caisse du coc vie des piles est
ya cette gare en ukraine et puis tout
d'un coup on a l'impression que l'europe
elle avance encore très vite tout d'un
coup oui vous savez c'est ce que disait
jean monnet et 10 l europe se fera dans
les crises sera la somme des solutions
qu'on apportera la crise la phrase de
jean monnet dans ses mémoires apparaît
véritablement la concrète effectivement
comme vous venez de dire nous avons subi
depuis quelques jours une véritable
révolution culturelle idéologique et
stratégique dans l'europe pour la
première fois rappelez-vous l'allemagne
la politique devait lebron c'était lost
politique c'était aller vers l'est et
madame merkel pendant 16 ans de pouvoir
ne voulait pas non plus se fâcher avec
vladimir poutine alors que son jeu était
clair au final eda en quelques jours un
gouvernement dirigé par un chancelier
social-démocrate avec des verts au
pouvoir et bien fait une véritable
révolution politique et stratégique
acceptent de contribuer à l'aso
sanctions économiques très importantes
contre la russie accepte d'acheter des
armes et des envoyés en ukraine alors
que ya ne serait-ce qu'une dizaine de
jours au la chasse allait proposer
uniquement envoyé 5000 casques à
l'allemagne avait été la risée du monde
entier fellahs ont donc jour finalement
c'est 450 voilà en deux roues qui on est
en quête vraie révolution et je dirais
que finalement ça donne une occasion non
seulement à emmanuel macron mais à tous
les parlementaires européens qui veulent
faire l'europe à la commission
européenne est bien de faire un pas en
avant très important vers un
renforcement une renforcement de
l'intégration européenne
la défense européenne le fonds de
défense européen vous avez cité l'europe
de la santé la réindustrialisation de
l'europe et je crois que c'est
véritablement quelque chose de salutaire
finalement pour l'europe mais ça il ya
une question de me poser ce que les
citoyens européens eux ils suivent le
mouvement est ce qu'ils sont pour
justement
une europe plus forte une europe
défensif plus forte notamment en
allemagne qui je crois qu'en fait tout
le monde a envie d'être protégés dans la
vie je pense que c'est un sentiment
assez partagé je pense qu'on a envie que
des propres et protégé que nos enfants
soient protégés et en fait au delà des
questions idéologiques je pense qu'il ya
une envie de voir des actions concrètes
regardé au monde la crise du coc vide
tout le monde a regardé l'europe mais à
dix mais aidez nous finalement et tout
le monde était choqué parce que en fait
on ne pouvait pas parce qu'on n'avait
pas le budget ni la compétence ni le
droit de le faire et ça a fait bouger
les lignes en fait les européens nous en
gardons mais pourquoi il ya de l'aide
qui arrive de partout et pas et pas de
l'europe donc je pense que là c'est
exactement la même chose dans ce domaine
là je crois que ce qui paiera ce sont
les actes que nous les aimons que nous
allons poser et j'ai l'impression que
oui pour une fois on va pas bouger très
très vite et c'est à dire celle hier à
être c'est unique cette guerre a été un
électrochoc à dire cela von der leyen la
présidente de la commission européenne
on va l'écouter tout de suite
we want to day la façon dont nous
répondons aujourd'hui est ce que fait la
russie déterminera l'avenir du système
international
le destin de l'ukraine est en jeu mais
notre propre dessin est également dans
la balance
nous devons montrer la puissance free
réside dans nos démocraties je suis
notre propre destin dans la balance ça
pourrait passer par quoi concrètement
cette europe de la défense est ce que ça
passe obligatoirement par l'otan alors
c'est une bonne question parce que c'est
vrai qu'il ya toujours cette ambivalence
à bruxelles entre l'union européenne
d'un côté puis le siège de l'otan de
l'autre et très souvent on pourrait
presque y avait l'impression que ce sont
des parents divorcés d'une même entité
un l'europe et quand on danse
quelquefois se re regarder le dos tourné
là tout toutefois il faut quand même
remarquer une chose c'est qu'on a quand
même 23 des alliés de l'otan qui sont
aussi membres de l'union européenne on a
deux pays la suède et la finlande dont
on parle aujourd'hui et qui commence à
bouger dans une direction plutôt
favorable à l'intégration
dans l'otan là encore les lignes sont en
train de changer et puis bien évidemment
il y as est cette volonté peut-être des
américains de l'it from behind c'est à
dire de regarder un petit peu les
européens faire avec quand même des
ambiguïtés qui ne sont pas encore
totalement résolus notamment sur le fait
de les européens font mais avec du
matériel américain est donc cette
question là elle n'est pas toujours
tranché mais ce qu'il faut bien voir
c'est que un pilier européen au sein de
l'otan il n'est pas absolument
inconcevable de l'imaginer et il n'est
pas non plus inimaginable de penser que
l'union européenne pourrait se doter des
instruments militaires des capacités
militaires à pouvoir faire avec un
état-major de l'union européenne les
structures ou du moins l'organisation de
ces structures existent déjà c'est
presque encore embryonnaire mais ça
pourrait monter en gamme là encore ça ça
reste quand même encore modeste
rappelons que sur à peu près des 50
mille fonctionnaires européens
il y en a à peu près 400 seulement qui
sont militaires donc on est quand même
loin d'avoir des militaires dans toutes
les structures mais cette idée d'aller
un peu plus loin et de travail et
pourquoi pas ici fonctionnent savoir
l'otan je pense que on verra peut-être
ce qu'il y aura au sommet de madrid au
mois de juin prochain où probablement on
aura encore un une joint-venture une
déclaration commune en trottant et e qui
ira tira plus loin
oui je reviens tout à fait je rejoins ce
qui vient d'être dit mais par rapport à
leurs hôtes scepticisme on disait
souvent les citoyens il ya de
l'euroscepticisme on est on est contre
une europe intégrée contre une europe
fédérale et finalement quand vous parlez
avec les citoyens mais que fait que fait
l'europe ne pouvons pas faire autre
chose séparément il faut que vraiment
reçu ni ce qu'on soit européen tant
qu'il ya véritablement un soutien des
citoyens et des citoyennes en faveur de
l'europe on peut discuter sur cette
forme d'europe mais on nous dit
aujourd'hui c'est plus possible d'être
tout seul faut qu'on soit fort ensemble
et là on s'aperçoit effectivement que
l'europe est très fragile et en fin de
compte ya une sorte de réflexe de survie
survie politique on s'aperçoit que nous
sommes très fragiles et lorsqu'on écoute
vol demi rennaise qui le président
ukrainien il nous dit mais pourquoi vous
nous avez dit il je veux m'accrocher je
veux montrer à l'europe parce que la
prochaine fois ce sera la lettonie la
hutte annie éventuellement à la pologne
qui seront attaqués doxa comprenez le
bien à travers l'ukraine c'est toute
l'europe qui est menacé alors qu'ils
menaient sur ce point là on a aussi vécu
quand même interview des évolutions
assez historique voir la finlande
s'interroger sur son adhésion à l'aide à
l'otan même chose du côté de lassus elle
s'est quand même deux choses qui étaient
il ya quelques semaines ah c'est
inenvisageable il faut bien faut bien se
rendre compte et ensuite sur la question
de l'otan
certains pays ont peur tout simplement
je veux dire c'est qu'ils ont de quoi et
c'est pour ça en fait que certains pays
aussi où vont vers l'otan on entend
beaucoup parler au bandana dis je
défendrai ce chaque centimètre carré des
pays de l'otan
mais quand on voit ce qui se passe en
ukraine on imagine que les pays qui n'en
font pas partie ont
qu on entend certains propos sur l'otan
et ses soi disant parce que l'ukraine
voulait se rapprocher de l'otan qui
aurait cette invasion faut bien se
rendre compte que il ya aucune annexion
américaine via l'otan de l'ue craignent
à juste des pays qui ont peur et je
pense qu'ils ont droit d'avoir peur et
s'est largement justifiée l'europe qui
est trop dépendante pour se défendre
mais qui est aussi trop dépendante en
matière d'énergie ça emmanuel macron l'a
rappelé aussi hier soir ça va être
compliqué à court terme de se passer du
gaz russe on imagine c'est un choc
énorme voilà j'ai toujours bataillé au
parlement européen contre au nord stream
1 et 2 pour des raisons
environnementales et géopolitique
est ce que ça nous mettait en danger et
l'allemagne certain nombre de politiques
allemands une responsabilité majeure
dans ce domaine oui c'est dur de se
débarrasser du on n'en dépend à 50 %
certains pays en dépendent à 100% si on
se passe du gaz russe
aujourd'hui il faut se rendre compte que
c'est un choc qui n'est pas celui du
choc pétrolier c'est au delà ce que choc
pétrolier ont été beaucoup moins
dépendants et consommateurs d énergie
fossile
la lotte au moins on a une vraie
augmentation dé la consommation des
énergies fossiles donc ses aveux dit les
pays ne sont pas exposés de la même
manière on a des pays à l'aise qu'ils
vont dépendre à 100% la france on est
autour en fonction des études entre 17
et 23 l'allemagne beaucoup plus mais on
est tous dans le même bateau en fait il
faut se rendre compte qu aujourd'hui il
même si je suis totalement opposé au gaz
on est dans une situation vraiment très
compliqué et il nous faut a minima un
plan marshall pour mettre en place des
renouvelables tout de suite on
n'arrivera pas à compenser à mon sens la
coupure du gaz russe par de
l'importation à faut savoir 70 % du gaz
arrive par des gazoducs 30% par par
compte et par bateau on n'arrivera pas
en fait à à compenser totalement même si
on fait une diversification ça veut dire
qu'il va falloir probablement avoir
recours au charbon on n'arrivera pas à
relancer certaines centrales qui était
en train d'être arrêté relance pas une
centrale nucléaire comme ça du jour au
lendemain donc ça veut dire que si on se
décide et qui est un vrai sujet et qui
s'entend je le partage en partie mais si
on décide de se couper du gaz russe on
rentre dans un moment va falloir choisir
de faire des priorités qu'est-ce qu'on
coupe qu'est-ce qu'on utilise qu'est-ce
que prioritaire le chauffage et on en
parlera justement dans la deuxième dans
la deuxième partie des conséquences sur
sur les citoyens européens
il est 19h30 31 ici à paris 20h30 et
inna à kiev on va refaire un point si
vous voulez bien sur la situation en
ukraine sur le terrain au huitième jour
de son offensive l'armée russe pilonne
toujours les villes ukrainiennes après
avoir pris personne au sud elle resserre
son étau notamment sur le port
stratégique de marioupol kiev la
capitale elle se prépare à un assaut de
grande ampleur regardez tout de suite ce
reportage de nos envoyés spéciaux
sur place
pour sortir de kiev seuls quelques
routes sécurisées loin de la puissance
de frappe des russes
les barrages sont nombreux les
ukrainiens sur leurs gardes
et vous avez eu combien attaque saut un
autre beau week-end tata
group
lui était avocat avant la guerre ces
sommes des civils qui ont pris des armes
mot people
the possibility to
[Applaudissements]
dance est ukraine attaquer les sons
c'est devenu rare
chacun doit faire des réserves pour le
voyage
comme tant d'autres cette famille qui a
quitté kiev et traumatisé
le monde ils attaquent sans distinction
quelle que soit la nationalité la langue
la race moi je suis arménienne et les
rues cherche à me tuer parce que j'aime
le créneau xavi
derrière moi vous pouvez le voir de
longues files d'attentes des voitures
qui attendent de passer car il y à des
barrages sur toutes les routes d'ukraine
mais c'est l'ukrainien n'ont pas eu le
choix que de quitter leurs maisons pour
aller soit à l'étranger ou dans des
zones où il n'y a pas encore de combat
dit cela dit on va écouter tout de suite
vladimir poutine le président russe qui
s'est exprimé tout à l'heure il ya un
peu plus d'une heure vladimir poutine
qui estime que son plan se déroule comme
prévu
autre chose qu'aux êtres chers camarades
je tiens à dire que l'opération
militaire spéciale se déroule
strictement dans le respect du
calendrier selon le plan
tous les objectifs fixés sont atteints
avec succès aux stress non échelle
avant de repartir sur l'europe ça se
déroule vraiment comme prévu pour
vladimir poutine c'est quoi son plan je
suis pas la tête de l'état major russe
et il ya eu une fake news la semaine
dernière je crois dimanche dernier qui a
raconté que le chef d'état major de
l'armée russe velay
gasimov aurait été justement dégager ce
n'était pas pour l'instant le cas je là
aussi signalé qu'il ya comme on dirait
un jeu de guerre ans rappelle un wargame
qui a été fait par le corps des marines
il ya quelques jours de cela justement
sur une situation de l'invasion de
l'ukraine et qui au regard de la
situation actuelle montre que finalement
les mêmes défaillances les mêmes
rapidité ou les mêmes défauts ont été
aurait été signalée c'est à dire que
quand quelque part
poutine annoncent que les choses se
passent sans accroc je pense qu'il faut
pas acheter ça à 100 % mais probablement
que oui certaines choses vont et se
déroule finalement moins mal que prévu
en revanche ce qui est très net c'est
que l'opération sur kiev elle
probablement a échoué et notamment que
la volonté était peut-être de s'emparer
très rapidement de la ville et de faire
chuter et par la capitale et peinant par
le gouvernement la totalité du
dispositif est que il ya peut-être eu
une résistance inattendue est
extrêmement forte et de la part de des
unités ukrainienne et même de toute la
population qui change un petit peu la
donne et on voit de jour en jour monter
cette résistance et là je crois que la
difficulté pour pour l'opération
spéciale elle est que le rythme se
ralentir ou devenir beaucoup plus
brutale depuis le début de cette guerre
en ukraine les européens se sont montrés
plus où me que jamais oublier les
postures de défiance on en parlait tout
à l'heure vis-à-vis de l'union de la
part de certains pays volodymyr zelensky
le président ukrainien d'ailleurs salué
cette unité européenne cette semaine
dans l'écoutent
j je suis heureux que nous ayons réussi
à vous réunir tous aujourd'hui les pays
de l'union européenne mais je ne savais
pas que ce serait un tel prix et c'est
une tragédie pour moi une tragédie pour
chaque ukrainien une tragédie pour notre
état
il le rock sera beaucoup plus fort avec
l'ukraine en son sein
sans vous l'ukraine sera seul
nous avons trouvé notre force
nous avons montré que nous sommes les
mêmes que vous
donc prouver que vous êtes avec nous
et que vous n'allez pas nous laisser
tomber
prouver que vous êtes vraiment européens
et alors la ville en portera sur la mort
la lumière l'emportera sur l'obscurité
voilà volodymyr zelensky qui s'exprimait
en début de semaine devant les députés
européens
patrick martin geniez l'europe qui s'est
montrée unie depuis le début de cette
crise même des pays comme la pologne ou
encore la hongrie qui d'habitude en sont
plus tôt
en retrait oui mais là la situation est
extraordinaire ce sont des pays qui ont
vécu sous le joug communiste pendant des
années et naturellement ils ont toujours
su que la russie constituait un danger
potentiel donc en quelque sorte
l'ukraine ce sont des pays frères ce
sont des pays qui ont vécu les mêmes
choses qu'eux et donc ils ont accueilli
à bras ouverts les réfugiés il faut
surtout quoi se féliciter de l'accueil
de la hongrie notamment la roumanie
compte accueilli effectivement ces
réfugiés même s'ils n'ont pas toujours
eu la même attitude vis-à-vis des
réfugiés syriens ou à faisant alors que
juridiquement ce sont des réfugiés qui
relève de la convention de genève donc
sur le même point il est vrai que nous
avons eu de graves divergences avec la
pologne qui ne respectent pas les droits
l'état de droit la hongrie la pologne
qui sont en délire il ya une procédure
d'infraction contre eux ils ne
respectent pas la presse l'indépendance
des juges ni le respect des minorités
mais aujourd'hui face à cette situation
extraordinaire on met les divergences
sous le boisseau ceci dit le vau l'eau
de mer et nas qui est tout à fait raison
de se féliciter d'une terreau pn mais je
ne pense pas que demain tout le monde
soit d'accord par exemple sur l'adhésion
de l'ukraine à l'union européenne ce que
veut aujourd'hui le président ukrainien
il lance un appel au secours edit je
veux comme octroie je crois que le
parlement européen s'est prononcé là
dessus comme comme octroie le plus
rapidement possible statut de pays
candidat c'est une une demande politique
symbolique qui est demandé mais vous
savez que l'adhésion de ce pays à
supposer que le président ukrainien
reste au pouvoir s'il n'est pas
renversée et bien ça prendra beaucoup de
temps car il ya toute une procédure ya
d'autres pays qui ont suivi la géorgie
qui a demandé officiellement d'entrée
dans l'union européenne et la moldavie
aujourd'hui mon avis qui a peur oui tout
à fait oui ce sont des procédures qui
sont très longues il ya une possibilité
de procédures accélérées kiné qui est
qui n'est pas utilisé comme ça donc ça
va prendre du temps là ce qu'on a ouvert
au parlement européen c'est la
possibilité d'étudier le dossier il faut
savoir néanmoins qu'il ya des accords
d'association qui sont déjà prêts et
créer et visiter entre entre l'union et
l'ukraine donc ça veut dire qu'il ya
déjà eu un début d'adaptation au droit
communautaire et c'est donc après c'est
une décision politique est-ce que côté
côté conseil c'est à dire les états
membres vont décider à l'unanimité
d'accélérer la procédure ou pas on va
voir mais il est sûr que cette semaine
le président ukrainien nos amis face à
nos responsabilités et nous a demandé
d'être à sa hauteur en fait et d'âtre
surtout à la hauteur des ukrainiens
est-ce que l'unité qui a été affiché
cette semaine par les européens peut
durer dans le temps ou c'est juste un
moment
bon je sais pas pour moi fatiha une
unité c'est une exigence on ne peut pas
ne pas être solidaire quand on voit cet
appel au secours de volodymyr élastique
est sous les bombes qui doit se déplacer
toutes les heures pour éviter d'être
assassinés parce que c'est bien ça dont
il s'agit je crois qu'il faut répondre
il faut qu'ils aient une exigence
politique et donc je crois que le
conseil européen des chefs d'état
gouvernement qui va se réunir bientôt
effectivement il faut que à l'unanimité
ils disent nous voulons d'ukraine dans
l'union européenne nous allons lui a
accordé même si toutes les conditions a
priori ne seraient pas remplies le
statut officiel de pays candidat à
l'union européenne ce sera un geste très
fort qu'il faut faire à son dga après
cela sur la question de l'unité je crois
qu'on est tous unis aussi parce qu'on a
peur tout simplement et que tout d'un
coup on est en train de remettre un peu
de l'ordre dans la hiérarchie des
priorités est de se rendre compte qu'on
est tous ensemble face à face à un
potentiel danger qui nous fait faire
montre de solidarité et par ailleurs je
crois que les négociations qui a pu
avoir ces derniers temps sur le système
swift dont on a beaucoup parlé avec
l'allemagne qui s'y est négocié
certaines choses italie aussi et la
belgique j'ai l'impression que c'est
très mal passé dans l'opinion publique
donc face à urs la faune d'ariane qui a
été tout à fait à la hauteur dans ses
discours très ferme et tout le monde
qu'ils étaient unis donc je pense
j'espère du moins qu'on va arrêter
d'assister à certains jeux politiques
qui ont fait du mal à l'europe qui l'ont
empêchée d'avancer c'est souvent les
états membres à campêche d'avancer leur
offre quand même le savoir et même chose
du côté de la pologne et la hongrie qui
peuvent être effectivement vous avez
rappelé qu'ils ont un nombre de dossiers
assez compliqué à gérer qui joue souvent
sur plusieurs tableaux là je pense même
chose que de moins j'espère peut-être un
peu mais j'espère qu'ils vont se rendre
compte qu'on a tous intérêt à être à
être unis ne pas pas faire de voile à ne
pas jouer en 3 est ce que je soutiens la
russie les états unis et ce que je suis
contre l'europe etc vous l'avez évoqué
le système swift ans a fait partie des
sanctions qui ont été prises par l'union
européenne des sanctions très dures
contre la russie des sanctions qui vont
avoir bien sûr des conséquences pour les
russes mais aussi pour les pour les
européens est ce que ces européens ils
sont prêts à subir les conséquences de
ces sanctions décidées par l'union
européenne non je vous répondrai c'est
toujours très difficile de savoir
comment les européens vont réagir
lorsqu'on parle quand même de 400
millions cinq cent millions d'habitants
donc avec des différences c'est à dire
plus vous habitez proche de la russie si
vous êtes au nord de la pologne aux
frontières avec kaliningrad si vous êtes
en estonie vous habitez tard tout est à
30 km vous avez la base de narva où les
forces russes sont si vous êtes en
revanche au portugal ou à chypre eh bien
vous voyez les choses de manière bien
différente
la conseil la conception géopolitique
d'une europe commune avec des priorités
communes c'est aussi être capable
j'allais dire de brest jusqu'à jusqu'à
varsovie et de oops alla jusqu'à
lisbonne d'avoir de s'entendre sur la
même chose et est donc la question c'est
face à un danger commun on peut être
unie mais l'unité et la notion même
d'alliance elle est toujours quelque
part de circonstance c'est comment est
ce qu'on arrive à tenir dans le temps
non moi ce que là dessus il ya peut-être
une une leçon à tirer non pas de ce que
fait très bien l'union européenne mais
c'est de regarder aussi comment
fonctionne peut-être le l'otan parce que
justement il ya ce côté là sur les
aspects purement défensive c'est par
exemple on ne vote pas par exemple à
l'otan on ne dise qu'on discute et
finalement toutes les discussions mènent
à une résolution commune au sens en
espèces de deux possibilités de se
séparer des autres et c'est peut-être ce
qui manque quelquefois à l'union
européenne où on discute peut-être trop
et dans ce domaine là ce qui était très
bien mais peut-être ce qui ne suffit pas
et le fait est que l'europe se réveille
le côté passé d'une europe du soft power
d'une europe de la norme une europe qui
est extrêmement forte dans ce domaine là
à une robe de la puissance c'est quelque
chose qui est qui va prendre du temps
mais qui est peut-être une démarche
essentielle pour finalement avoir la
totalité de ce qui était cité dans
discours du président d'un public la
notion d'une souveraineté alors bien
évidemment c'est complexe et peut-être
qu'on n'y sera pas eu de demain elles
mêmes seront isra peut-être même jamais
mais qu'on étudie ces mots là et qu'on
les utilise c'est dans l'ordre du
discours ma vie très intéressant mais
pour revenir aux citoyens européens
cette guerre elle va avoir des
conséquences très dur dans leur
quotidien emmanuel macron l'aladi encore
hier les prix de l'essence vont
augmenter si vous prenez votre voiture
ça va devenir plus compliqué le
chauffage va augmenter si on se chauffe
au gaz même à l'électricité
concrètement les européens s'ils
subissent toutes les conséquences de
cette guerre en ukraine est ce qu'il
n'ya pas un risque justement que ça
affaiblissent l'europe et qu'il ya un
espèce de repli sur soi dans chaque pays
en fait déjà faut partir d'un premier
point c'est qu'en fait quand on met des
sanctions sur un autre pays c'est
rarement seront douleur sur nous mêmes
voilà ça c'est c'est la base et il faut
je crois l'accepter se serrer les coudes
on n'est pas dans un moment simple ce
qu'il faut maintenant c'est par contre
protéger et à ce niveau là j'ai c'est le
quoi qu'il en coûte 1 va falloir va
falloir protéger énormément d'un point
de vue social parce qu'effectivement on
était déjà dans un épisode
inflationnistes liées aux matières
premières et aux prêts l'énergie qui
n'était pas bon là ça va être encore
moins bon ça veut dire qu'il va falloir
vous y faire des chèques pour que tout
le monde puisse s'en sortir à un moment
en plus où on parlait de hausses de
salaires dans la campagne présidentielle
qui est une nécessité un haut niveau au
niveau français il va falloir aussi
faire montre de solidarité au niveau
européen et dans chaque état membre je
pense aux aliments notamment la france
et des coupes dans les impôts qui sont
faites régulièrement je suis désolé mais
c'est pas possible il va falloir qu'on
trouve de l'argent et donc il ya
certaines personnes qui ne paye pas ses
impôts dans ce pays et il va falloir
qu'elle fasse elle aussi montre de
solidarité pour qu'on ait une
acceptation sociale
du conflit patrick martin génie je vois
que vous aviez envie de réagir non je
pense tout à fait ça qu'on ait un débat
politique qu'il faut aussi qu'
effectivement une discussion sur le type
d'imposition la fiscalité qu'on le veut
la justice sociale mais nous sommes
effectivement dans une situation tout à
fait extraordinaire et lorsqu'il ya une
guerre il y à des sacrifices et je crois
- en discutant avec des citoyens des
citoyens des gens me disent mais
évidemment qu'on est prêt à faire des
sacrifices
lorsque vous discutez avec les gens qui
conduisent des voitures le prix du
carburant augmente augmente donc ça va
être difficile mais aussi la justice
sociale et donc lorsqu'on est en guerre
et c'est bien la guerre il faut nous
défendre pour la liberté pour la
démocratie
nous sommes attaqués en plein coeur de
l'europe ça pourrait nous tomber dessus
à jour tant qu'il ya forcément des
sacrifices il faut accepter je pense que
les citoyens vont l'accepter mais que
ces sacrifices seront provisoires et
qu'on pourra après repartir sur un débat
pollution des sacrifices sur les modes
de vie sur le mode de vie mais également
oui l'énergie parce que regarder il faut
qu'on parle de la politique énergétique
vous disiez tout à fait justement new
seven 17 23 % l'allemagne c'est plus 60%
certains c'est 100% mais l'allemagne a
fait des choix énergétiques depuis un
certain temps qu'ils sont nés presque
des fastes l'allemagne a abandonné le
nucléaire continue à tirer le charbon à
exploiter du charbon et le ministre
allemand de l'économie a dit que toute
façon il n'arriverait pas à pourvoir
avec les énergies propres notamment
éolienne donc il ya une vraie difficulté
sachant que l'énergie propre en
allemagne et un débat parce que ça va
coûter cher aux catégories sociales les
plus défavorisées donc il ya un vrai
débat politique est ce niveau là mais
c'est ce qui veut dire qu'on doit
repartir sur un débat fondamental sur
une meilleure intégration européenne
plus de justice sociale et c'est tout le
débat européen que nous allons avoir
dans les années qui viennent donc il ya
un autre défi on l'a évoqué un petit peu
plus tôt c'est le défi migratoire car là
il ya plus d'un million d'ukrainiens qui
ont déjà franchi franchi la frontière il
se réfugie en pologne ou encore en
moldavie on sait qu en 2015
ça avait déstabilisé l'europe en la
vague migratoire venus de syrie est ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'europe peut faire face
à cette nouvelle vague migratoire alors
déjà qu'ils aient une différence par
rapport à 2015 ou même à ce que l'on a
observé par rapport à la biélorussie il
ya quelques il ya quelques mois de cela
où il y avait une instrumentalisation
des crises migratoires justement par par
certains régimes ou par certains pays là
c'est pas instrumentalisé par l'ukraine
véritablement serre que ses vrais
réfugiés là au contraire ils sont
accueillis et je crois bien qu'il ya une
véritable volonté des pays limitrophes
la roumanie la moldavie la pologne de
les accueillir et de les laisser
tranquilles transiger ou passer par leur
pays pour aller retrouver d'autres
d'autres endroits un peu plus loin en
slovaquie en hongrie etc etc et donc
quelque part n'y a pas d'
instrumentalisation de cette crise mais
un moment ou un autre
quand la crise sera finie faudra
peut-être assuré que ces gens là
reviennent en ukraine et la question
c'est que deviendra-t-il en réalité de
l'ukraine que va-t-il se passer donc pas
dans les jours mais dans les semaines et
dans les mois qui viennent parce que on
a bien à l'esprit ce qui s'est passé
avec la crise syrienne quelque part le
temporaire peut devenir ensuite du
permanent et ce qui a une véritable
volonté des européens d'accepter cela de
le supporter est là encore de de l'ain
n'ont pas de le voir comme étant une
difficulté mais peut-être une chance ou
quelque chose justement à utiliser au
mieux
oui la commission européenne vient de
déclencher des directives spécifiques
sur le sujet pour justement permettre à
tous les réfugiés de pouvoir transiter
où ils veulent sur sur le territoire
européen c'est s est autorisé sur la
base de 90 jours donc on est en cours de
négociation aujourd'hui l'insolent même
au niveau du conseil le principe a été
accepté pour déclenchement de cette
directive on est en train de faire voir
les détails parce que 90 jours ça ne
suffira probablement pas et donc pour
que les si les personnes ne se
retrouvent pas en situation d'illégalité
sur le territoire on est en train de
justement comment on peut faire en sorte
que ça dure plus longtemps mais en tout
cas là le plan est déclenché un dernier
mot oui non obstant les directives ya
quand même la corrosion genève sur les
réfugiés et chaque pays nous à travers
l'office français pour les réfugiés et
apatrides la possibilité de décerner des
titres des titres de séjour réfugiés et
donc je pense qu'il y aura des
directives en ce sens qu'en france on va
suivre ça de très près merci beaucoup
merci à tous les trois merci guillaume à
la scuderia ce merci patrick martin
geniez merci horreur laluque d'avoir été
avec nous ce soir pour ce débat sur
france 24 consacrait à l'europe et les
conséquences de la gare ans en ukraine
rester avec nous l'information continue